Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Alice: 我误打误撞竟然发现了切皮蛋的妙招
Alice: I accidentally discovered a great trick for cutting century eggs.
Alice: 那就是把它冷冻起来
Alice: You just freeze them.
Alice: 好的不是妙招切不动
Alice: Okay, not a great trick, they won't cut.
Alice: 比我的命都硬
Alice: They're harder than my life.
Katrina:  但是他不会乱溜
Katrina: But they won't slip around.
Katrina:  你知道我现在看你干所有的事情
Katrina: You know, everything you do now,
Katrina:  都觉得很神奇
Katrina: I find it so amazing.
Katrina:  因为我妈也不会做
Katrina: Because even my mom can't do it.
Katrina:  这种我从来没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this before.
Katrina:  有种非常崇拜的感觉
Katrina: I feel a sense of admiration.
Tasha: 把他们搅合到完全融合的状态
Tasha: Mix them until they are completely blended.
Tasha: 就是你既看不出来他像他
Tasha: So you can't tell that they look like them.
Tasha: 你看他现
Tasha: You see now,
Tasha: 在就是还有油花在那个最边边
Tasha: There are still oil spots on the edges.
Tasha: 嗯所以就还没有融合
Tasha: So it's not fully blended yet.
Tasha: 差不多就可以了吧
Tasha: It should be almost done.
Tasha: 可以再搅一下
Tasha: You can mix it a bit more.
Tasha: 我去拿下一个材料
Tasha: I'll go get the next ingredient.
Tasha: 哈哈哈可以
Tasha: Haha, it's good.
Tasha: 然后再放上去就可以
Tasha: Then you can put it on.
Tasha: 40克好像
Tasha: 40 grams, I think.
Tasha: 我没记错的话40克
Tasha: If I remember correctly, 40 grams.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 然后你可以搅一搅它
Tasha: Then you can mix it.
Lucia: 再搅一搅
Lucia: Mix it again.
Tasha: 对搅拌到看不出一点粉
Tasha: Yes, mix it until you can't see any powder.
Lucia: 看不出一点粉
Lucia: Until you can't see any powder.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 是这个意思吗
Lucia: Is this what it means?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, that's right.
小薇旁边壁上还有粉
Tasha: There's still some powder on the wall next to me.
Tasha: 然后搅拌的再顺滑一点
Tasha: Then mix it until it's smoother.
Lucia: 这个地方蹭的掉吗
Lucia: Can this spot be scrubbed off?
Alice: 我要开始了
Alice: I'm about to start.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  热水烧好了耶
Katrina: The hot water is ready!
Tasha: 嗯差不多可以这样
Tasha: Yeah, it's almost good like this.
Tasha: 然后再把三个蛋黄加进去
Tasha: Then add the three egg yolks.
Tasha: 你要来抽蛋黄吗
Tasha: Do you want to separate the egg yolks?
Katrina:  嗯我要
Katrina: Yeah, I want to.
Alice: 哎我们家的油呢
Alice: Hey, where's our oil?
Tasha: 呃玉米油行吗
Tasha: Uh, is corn oil okay?
Tasha: 随便玉米油
Tasha: Any corn oil will do.
Katrina:  这是后来加了什么
Katrina: What did we add later?
Katrina:  然后变成坨坨了
Katrina: And then it turned into clumps.
Alice: 呃给我一点点点纸好吗
Alice: Uh, can you give me a little bit of paper?
Lucia:啊是面粉吧
Lucia: Ah, it's flour, right?
Lucia: 我们加的
Lucia: We added it.
Lucia: OK牛奶加油加面
Lucia: Okay, milk, oil, and flour.
Tasha: OK可以了
Tasha: Okay, it's done.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me see.
Tasha: 嗯可以了
Tasha: Hmm, it's done.
Tasha: 到你了呵呵呵呵
Tasha: It's your turn, hahaha.
Alice: 我们的葱姜蒜呢
Alice: Where's our scallion, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜
Tasha: Scallion, ginger, and garlic.
Alice: 这里边
Alice: It's inside here.
Lucia: 在调料那一袋里面似乎
Lucia: Seems like it's in the seasoning bag.
小薇 就在调料里面
Tasha: It's just in the seasoning.
Katrina: 一个方向打就行
Katrina: Just beat it in one direction.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: where where
Alice: Where, where?
Alice: 我尊嘟很急
Alice: I'm really in a hurry.
Tasha: 把它搅拌为你就融合在一起就行
Tasha: Just mix it until it blends together.
Tasha: 你看现在没有融合对吧
Tasha: See, it's not blended now, right?
Alice: 嗯没有啊
Alice: Yeah, it's not.
Alice: 哦有
Alice: Oh, it is.
Katrina:  好神奇哦
Katrina: So magical.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: So tiring.
Alice: 我们那个现成的蒜呢
Alice: Where's our ready-to-use garlic?
Katrina:  现成的蒜
Katrina: Ready-to-use garlic?
Katrina:  冰箱里嗯
Katrina: It's in the fridge, yeah.
Alice: 现成的蒜
Alice: Ready-to-use garlic.
Alice: 是不是在那里边
Alice: Is it in there?
Tasha: 现成的蒜
Tasha: Ready-to-use garlic.
Tasha: 看一眼
Tasha: Let me take a look.
Tasha: 蒜蒜在这呀
Tasha: The garlic is here!
Alice: 不是蒜苗蒜就那个白白胖胖的
Alice: No, not the garlic sprouts, the white, plump garlic.
Alice: 嗯左左左左左上角
Alice: Uh, left, left, left, top left.
Alice: 那那那给我一点就行了
Alice: Just give me a little bit, that's fine.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Alice: 拿出来就行
Alice: Just take it out.
Lucia: 给
Lucia: Here.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: good哈哈哈
Tasha: Good, hahaha.
Tasha: OK然后差不多有时间的话
Tasha: OK, if we have time,
Tasha: 我们可以把楼上的那个打蛋盆拿下来
Tasha: we can bring down the egg whisking bowl from upstairs.
Lucia: 啊看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let me take a look.
Lucia: 现在没关系
Lucia: It's fine for now.
Lucia: 好像还差几分钟
Lucia: It seems like there's still a few minutes left.
Lucia: 三分钟
Lucia: Three minutes.
Tasha: 三分钟嗯
Tasha: Three minutes, yeah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 拿下来吧
Tasha: Let's bring it down.
Lucia: 可以啦 OK可以了没关系
Lucia: It's fine, OK, it's fine, no worries.
Alice: 没有围裙对吧
Alice: No aprons, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 好像没有就这吧
Alice: Seems like there's none, let's just go with this.
Katrina:  接下来做什么
Katrina: What are we doing next?
Tasha:接下来把蛋清
Tasha: Next, separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 就是刚刚蛋黄和蛋清要分开
Tasha: We need to separate the yolks and whites.
Tasha: 分开之后他们现在先把蛋清打发一下
Tasha: After separating, we'll whip the egg whites a bit.
Alice: 顺便帮我剥点蒜
Alice: Meanwhile, peel some garlic for me.
Jake:现在在做什么
Jake: What are we doing now?
Lucia: 呃小蛋糕
Lucia: Uh, little cakes.
Alice: 哎有人 有手吗
Alice: Hey, anyone free to help?
Katrina:  我帮你不
Katrina: Need help?
Alice: 那个是密密封的
Alice: That one's tightly sealed.
Alice: 我想等到你们那个火锅的时候再用
Alice: I wanted to wait until you guys start the hot pot to use it.
Katrina:  我帮你吧
Katrina: Let me help you.
Katrina:  好这个部分结束了
Katrina: Okay, this part is done.
Katrina:  就是把它
Katrina: Just put it...
Alice:: 啊这一点就行
Alice: Ah, just a little bit is fine.
Alice: 有点小不太好拨衣
Alice: It's a bit small, hard to peel.
Lucia: 来喽
Lucia: Here it comes.
Tasha: 来喽来喽的话要放在这
Tasha: Here it comes, it needs to be placed here.
Alice: 算了弄皮了
Alice: Forget it, it's peeled.
Alice: 就这样吧反正洗过
Alice: Just leave it, it's washed anyway.
Katrina:  天呐AI在我这采集数据可杂了
Katrina: Gosh, the AI collecting data from me is so messed up.
Katrina:  一会干这一会干那
Katrina: Doing this one moment, doing that the next.
Tasha: 然后能把白砂糖拿来吗
Tasha: Can you get the white sugar?
Lucia: 白砂糖在
Lucia: The white sugar is...
Alice:这这呢
Alice: It's right here.
Alice: 这个这个这个这个里面吧
Alice: It's in here.
Lucia: 这里面
Lucia: In here?
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Lucia: 哦这样
Lucia: Oh, like this.
Lucia: 哎这个白糖它可以撕开
Lucia: Hey, you can tear open this white sugar.
Lucia: 之后还能
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 那个拉链是吗
Lucia: There's a zipper, right?
Lucia: 对哎呦好疼
Lucia: Yeah, ouch, it hurts.
Tasha: 纸杯蛋糕的纸杯
Tasha: The cupcake liners.
Alice: 假装没看到
Alice: Pretend you didn't see it.
Tasha: 好了吗嗯稍等
Tasha: Is it ready? Uh, wait a sec.
Tasha: 我拿个纸杯当个容器
Tasha: I'll grab a cupcake liner to use as a container.
Tasha: 嗯哦  呵呵呵
Tasha: Hmm, oh, hehe.
Tasha: 好放35克
Tasha: Okay, 35 grams.
Lucia: 35克
Lucia: 35 grams.
Alice:: 我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 两个没事我点
Alice: Two are fine, I'll adjust it.
Alice: 这蒜太小了不好剥
Alice: This garlic is too small, hard to peel.
Tasha: 我天呐还有别的刀吗
Tasha: Oh my god, is there another knife?
Alice: 有底下呢
Alice: Yes, it's below.
Lucia: 嗯你看一眼
Lucia: Hmm, take a look.
Lucia: 这样可以吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Tasha:他倒了35克就行
Tasha: As long as it measures 35 grams.
Lucia: 倒了35.2吗
Lucia: Is it 35.2 grams?
Tasha: 没关系待会用倒
Tasha: It's fine, we'll use it later.
Tasha: 哦不餐巾纸
Tasha: Oh no, paper towels.
Tasha: 任何东西都不能沾水
Tasha: Nothing can touch water.
Alice: 难剥
Alice: Hard to peel.
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Lucia:然后我把这个白糖放到哎这上面
Lucia: Then I'll put this sugar on top here.
Lucia: 好像已经放满了的样子
Lucia: Looks like it's already full.
Lucia: 管他呢给他挤一点位置出来
Lucia: Never mind, I'll make some space for it.
Tasha: 好然后
Tasha: Okay, then...
Tasha: 你看他现在是蛋清的样子对吧
Tasha: See, it looks like egg whites now, right?
Tasha: 嗯好然后这是35克
Tasha: Yeah, okay, this is 35 grams.
Tasha: 好这么多，这蒜真不好剥
Tasha: Alright, that's a lot. This garlic is really hard to peel.
Tasha: 先低速再高速
Tasha: Low speed first, then high speed.
Tasha: 第一遍只要打出这种细
Tasha: The first round, just beat it until it's fine like this.
Alice: 你们是不是明天用火锅就行
Alice: Are you guys using the hotpot tomorrow?
Katrina:  应该是明天晚上吧
Katrina: Probably tomorrow night.
Alice: 受不了了我要用那个蒜了
Alice: I can't stand it, I need to use the garlic now.
Katrina:  要等他回来才
Katrina: We have to wait for him to come back first.
Tasha: 呃再帮我取5克玉米淀粉吧
Tasha: Uh, can you get me 5 grams of cornstarch?
Lucia: 呃15克
Lucia: Uh, 15 grams.
Lucia: 5克呃
Lucia: 5 grams, uh...
Lucia: 5克
Lucia: 5 grams.
Tasha: 用这个用这个取
Tasha: Use this, use this to measure.
Lucia: 这个就先拿下来
Lucia: I'll just take this down first.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: OK.
Katrina:  还要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Do we need to add lemon?
Tasha:加过了
Tasha: Already added.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  为什么要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Why do we need to add lemon?
Tasha: 去腥
Tasha: To remove the fishy smell.
Katrina:  哦哈哈
Katrina: Oh, haha.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
小薇 嗯对对对5克就行
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, 5 grams will do.
Tasha: 然后第二遍是这个状态就行
Tasha: Then the second round, it should be in this state.
Lucia: 哇嗯
Lucia: Wow, okay.
Tasha: 然后最后一遍
Tasha: Then the last round.
Lucia: 好神奇蛋清竟然会打成这样
Lucia: So amazing that egg whites can be beaten like this.
Lucia: 等一下这个要把它再清理一下吗
Lucia: Wait, do we need to clean this again?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 5克
Tasha: 5 grams.
Tasha: 可以可以好给我吧
Tasha: Okay, okay, great, give it to me.
Alice: 好我们是没有汤勺
Alice: Okay, we don't have a soup spoon.
Alice: 应该有吧
Alice: We should have one, right?
Alice: 没有汤勺
Alice: No soup spoon.
Alice: 在后面
Alice: It's at the back.
Lucia: 汤勺我好像也没看见
Lucia: I don't think I've seen a soup spoon either.
Lucia: 看他们这有没有
Lucia: Let's see if they have one.
Lucia: 是卖的哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh, they are selling it, haha.
Lucia: 这样先晃一下吧
Lucia: Let's shake it first.
Tasha: 希望他不会拒绝吧
Tasha: Hope he won't refuse.
Katrina:  爱上了打蛋
Katrina: Fell in love with beating eggs.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Tasha: 打发成这样子能提起来
Tasha: If it's whipped like this, you can lift it.
Tasha: 然后他不会
Tasha: And then he won't...
Tasha: 他你看他这个有个尖尖
Tasha: See, there's a little peak.
Tasha: 他不会掉下来就说明就打完了
Tasha: If it doesn't fall, it means it's done.
Alice: 一步是要把水锅里的水给蒸发一下
Alice: One step is to evaporate the water in the pot a bit.
Alice: 不然他会怎么样
Alice: Otherwise, what will happen?
Tasha: 就是一个废气
Tasha: It's just exhaust.
Alice: 他会啪啦啪啦的
Alice: It will go pop, pop.
Alice: 就是水跟油不香
Alice: Water and oil don't smell good together.
Alice: 他们不是好朋友
Alice: They are not friends.
Alice: 他们会打架
Alice: They will fight.
Alice: 居然是玉米油
Alice: It's actually corn oil.
Katrina:  我们俩特别像学生
Katrina: We really look like students.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  这老师在干什么
Katrina: What's the teacher doing?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 然后有种接受培训的感觉
Lucia: It feels like we're in training.
Katrina:  我们在新东方啊
Katrina: We're at New Oriental, huh?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 把这个分三次划进去
Tasha: Add this in three batches.
Tasha: 第一遍的话就只有分三遍刮
Tasha: For the first time, you divide it into three parts.
Tasha: 他才会充分融合
Tasha: Then it will fully blend.
Tasha: 第一遍的话他不是会很充分
Tasha: The first time, it won't fully blend.
Tasha: 你可能觉得他充分了
Tasha: You might think it's well blended.
Tasha: 但其实没那么充分
Tasha: But it's actually not.
Katrina:  这个白色的就是刚刚蛋清加了什么的
Katrina: This white stuff is just egg whites with what?
Tasha: 蛋清加了糖啊
Tasha: Egg whites with sugar.
Katrina:  蛋清加了糖就变成这样了对
Katrina: Egg whites with sugar turn into this, right?
Katrina:  蛋清刚刚不是液体吗
Katrina: Wasn't the egg white liquid just now?
Katrina:  现在怎么变成橡皮体
Katrina: How did it turn into rubber now?
Katrina:  嗯因为那个机器打就是啊
Katrina: Hmm, it's because the machine whipped it, right?
Katrina:  然后他就会起泡
Katrina: And then it starts to foam.
Lucia: 对好神奇的哦 哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, it's so amazing. Hahaha.
Katrina:  amazing
Katrina: Amazing.
Katrina:  蛋清加了蛋清
Katrina: Added more egg whites.
Tasha: 然后加第二次进去
Tasha: Then added the second batch.
Alice: 其实我放错顺序
Alice: Actually, I did it in the wrong order.
Alice: 我应该先放皮蛋的
Alice: I should have added the century eggs first.
Tasha: 嗯我觉得应该先把烤箱预热
Tasha: Hmm, I think we should preheat the oven first.
Lucia: 要预热一下吗
Lucia: Should we preheat it a bit?
Lucia: 等一下
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Tasha: 热水在吗
Tasha: Is the hot water ready?
Tasha: 在
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 有点水没关系哦
Tasha: A little water is fine.
Lucia: 要擦一下吗
Lucia: Should we wipe it off?
Tasha: 哦可以擦一下
Tasha: Oh, you can wipe it.
Tasha: 哦谢谢
Tasha: Oh, thank you.
Tasha: 哦对然后我们把这个第二个
Tasha: Oh yeah, then we put the second one.
Alice: 粘锅了
Alice: It's sticking to the pan.
Alice: 哦啊
Alice: Oh no.
Tasha: 预热一下的
Tasha: Preheat it.
Tasha: 话烤箱里的温度更好
Tasha: The temperature inside the oven will be better.
Lucia: OK啊边上这个也擦一下吧
Lucia: OK, let's wipe this side too.
Tasha: 看其实你以为很融合
Tasha: See, you think it's well-mixed.
Tasha: 但其实还是没那么融合
Tasha: But it's actually not that mixed.
Tasha: 所以就是要分三遍
Tasha: So you need to do it in three parts.
Lucia:要分次
Lucia: In batches.
Tasha: 对然后你可以把纸杯蛋糕放上去
Tasha: Yeah, then you can put the cupcakes on.
Lucia: 放到这个
Lucia: Put them on this.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia:托盘上
Lucia: On the tray.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  然后排起开烤
Katrina: Then line them up and start baking.
Tasha: 这就是我们的蛋糕胚部分就完成了
Tasha: And that's how we finish the cake base part.
Katrina:  哦然后就把它舀进去就好了
Katrina: Oh, then just scoop it in.
Lucia:哦原来蛋糕胚是这样做的
Lucia: Oh, so that's how you make the cake base.
Lucia: 6个我们这个需要几个
Lucia: We need six, how many can this make?
Katrina:  大概能装多少个
Katrina: How many can it fill approximately?
Tasha: 呃这个
Tasha: Uh, this...
Tasha: 哈哈哈 好
Tasha: Hahaha, okay.
Katrina: 装了再说吧
Katrina: Let's just put it in first.
Tasha: 就就这样放着吧
Tasha: Just leave it like that.
Lucia: 行呃
Lucia: Alright, um...
Tasha: 不太能确定
Tasha: Not really sure.
Lucia: 没事装完要是不够
Lucia: It's okay, if it's not enough after filling...
Lucia: 我们再拿出几个杯子
Lucia: We can get a few more cups.
Tasha: 可以放到这个里面
Tasha: We can put it in here.
Tasha: 因为这个有个嘴
Tasha: Because this has a spout.
Tasha: 他好倒啊
Tasha: It's easy to pour.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 所以这个杯子他既可以倒嘴
Tasha: So this cup can not only pour...
Tasha: 然后呢他还有容容量
Tasha: But it also has capacity.
Katrina:  这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Tasha: 呃叫鸟嘴杯
Tasha: Uh, it's called a beak cup.
Tasha: 鸟嘴杯只要做烘焙都会买的
Tasha: Anyone who does baking will buy one.
Tasha: 好了然后就就倒就行了
Tasha: Alright, just pour it in.
Tasha: 大家可以都试试
Tasha: Everyone can give it a try.
Tasha: 倒到差不多这里
Tasha: Pour it to about here.
Tasha: 因为它会膨膨胀起来嘛
Tasha: Because it will expand.
Lucia: 哦嗯
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 咦你先来啊
Lucia: Uh, you go first.
Katrina:  好你先打样
Katrina: Okay, you go ahead and show us.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我们学习一下如何倒
Lucia: Let's learn how to pour.
Katrina:  啊差不多这么多就行啊
Katrina: Uh, about this much should be good, right?
Lucia: 来慢慢了解啊
Lucia: Take your time to get the hang of it.
Lucia: 我试一下谢谢
Lucia: Let me try, thanks.
Tasha: 好了好
Tasha: Alright, good.
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Tasha: 挪果断的挪没关系哈哈
Tasha: Move decisively, it's okay, haha.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Katrina:  可以好像可以再倒一点什么
Katrina: Maybe we can pour a little more or something.
Lucia: 姐妹你来
Lucia: Sister, you go.
Lucia: 他好像滴出来了一点点
Lucia: It seems like a little bit dripped out.
Tasha:没关系没关系
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 在边上没事吧
Lucia: It's on the side, is it okay?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 继续倒吧
Tasha: Keep pouring.
Lucia: 对可以再倒一点
Lucia: Yeah, you can pour a bit more.
Lucia: 感觉好像没有特别多
Lucia: Feels like there's not that much.
Katrina:  差不多了
Katrina: It's almost enough.
Katrina:  好，给我吧
Katrina: Okay, give it to me.
Lucia: 是不是挨近一点
Lucia: Should I get closer?
Tasha: 瓜瓜还能再来一杯
Tasha: Gua Gua can have another cup.
Lucia: 呃再放一个杯子啊
Lucia: Uh, put another cup?
Katrina:  不用啊
Katrina: No need.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: OK最后我一共烤了10个嗯哼
Tasha: OK, I baked a total of 10, mhm.
Tasha: 然后我们送入烤箱就可以
Tasha: Then we can put them in the oven.
Lucia: 要按一下哪里
Lucia: Where do I press?
Lucia: 哦那让他
Lucia: Oh, let him do it.
Lucia: 那个表为什么又倒了
Lucia: Why did the timer reset?
Tasha: 哦你看它这温度其实不准
Tasha: Oh, look, the temperature is actually inaccurate.
Tasha: 烤箱温度显示它已经
Tasha: The oven temperature shows it has...
Katrina:  哇好可爱
Katrina: Wow, so cute.
Alice: 感觉好像坏掉了
Alice: Feels like it's broken.
Alice: 算了不放它
Alice: Forget it, don't put it.
Katrina:  这大概烤多久啊
Katrina: How long does this bake?
Tasha: 呃50分钟
Tasha: Uh, 50 minutes.
Tasha: 正好吃饭吃完饭吧
Tasha: Perfect timing, we can have dinner after.
Tasha: 行了
Tasha: All good.
Tasha: 第一次是口烤20分钟
Tasha: First time, bake for 20 minutes.
Katrina:  啊分分次的
Katrina: Oh, in intervals.
Tasha: 对他先低温烤熟
Tasha: Yes, bake at low temperature first.
Tasha: 然后高温上色啊
Tasha: Then high temperature for coloring.
Katrina:  好好玩
Katrina: So fun.
Tasha: 他如果盯了之后
Tasha: If it’s done and I’m not here...
Tasha: 我如果不在的话就是他这个时间到了
Tasha: When the time is up...
Tasha: 20分钟就到了
Tasha: After 20 minutes...
Tasha: 嗯然后你把这个上火调成130
Tasha: Then you set the top heat to 130.
Tasha: 下火也调成130
Tasha: Bottom heat also to 130.
Tasha: 再打30分钟
Tasha: Bake for another 30 minutes.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Lucia: OK 13013030我要去上厕所
Lucia: OK, 130, 130, 30. I need to go to the bathroom.
Tasha: yes然后我们要把残垃圾清理掉
Tasha: Yes, then we need to clean up the leftover trash.
Tasha: 尤其是这个盆
Tasha: Especially this bowl.
Tasha: 因为等会咱们还得再打奶油
Tasha: Because we need to whip the cream later.
Tasha: 也是用它的
Tasha: We'll use it again.
Lucia: OK OK这些这些纸就先先扔了吧
Lucia: OK, OK, let's just throw these papers away first.
Tasha: 对全部都扔掉
Tasha: Yeah, throw them all away.
Tasha: 这个是洗一下
Tasha: This one needs to be washed.
Tasha: 然后全部都洗
Tasha: Then wash everything.
Tasha: 然后擦干
Tasha: And then dry them.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Lucia: 这个哎
Lucia: This, hey...
Lucia: 那我就把这个菜先拿出来
Lucia: I'll just take these vegetables out first.
Lucia: 菜放这就会
Lucia: Put the veggies here.
Lucia: 嗯这边水倒掉一点吧
Lucia: Hmm, let's pour out some of this water.
Tasha: 对我把垃圾收一下
Tasha: Yeah, I'll take care of the trash.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Tasha: 这些都是要洗的
Tasha: All of these need to be washed.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Alice: 白菜呢嗯
Alice: Where's the cabbage, hmm?
Lucia: 在这里我害怕洗那个什么
Lucia: It's here. I was afraid to wash it...
Lucia: 洗到里面我就把它拿出来了
Lucia: ...so I took it out.
Alice: 涮一下这个
Alice: Rinse this.
Lucia: 呃咱这应该有抹布吧
Lucia: Uh, we should have a cloth here, right?
Tasha: 有吧
Tasha: Should be.
Lucia: 没有的话
Lucia: If not...
Lucia: 哎呀那个那个那个海绵有点脏
Lucia: Oh man, that sponge is a bit dirty.
Lucia: 不是很想用啊
Lucia: Don't really want to use it.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: Here's another one.
Lucia: 这给他扔过去哎
Lucia: Let's throw this over there, hey.
Jake: 开饭了
Jake: Time to eat.
Tasha: 哦烤上啦
Tasha: Oh, it's roasting.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 虽然完全不知道怎么做的
Jake: Even though I have no idea how to make it.
Jake: 但是一定很好吃
Jake: But it must taste good.
Tasha: 谢谢你嗯
Tasha: Thank you, mm.
Tasha: 这个也快好了好像
Tasha: This one is almost ready too, I think.
Jake: 哦怎么个
Jake: Oh, how...
Jake: 发起来的是吧
Jake: It's rising, right?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 哦可以没事你们踩到了数据
Jake: Oh, it's fine. You guys stepped on the data.
Tasha: 哈哈哈他晚上回去看数据
Tasha: Hahaha, he'll check the data tonight.
Jake:哈哈哈  对
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake: 让世界研究员们都看到
Jake: Let the researchers around the world see this.
Jake: 这个鸡蛋哎
Jake: This egg, hey.
Jake: 怎么打碎了呀
Jake: How did it break?
Jake: 打碎的瞬间
Jake: The moment it broke
Alice: 为什么这个汤变成这个样子
Alice: Why did this soup turn out like this?
Jake: 这是咋回事
Jake: What's going on here?
Alice: 好暗啊
Alice: It's so dark.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:这是怎么发生的什么
Jake: How did this happen?
Tasha: 这是鸡蛋
Tasha: It's an egg.
Tasha: 不小心它自己跑到桌上了哦
Tasha: It accidentally ended up on the table by itself.
Jake: 就是鸡蛋变成了鸡
Jake: So the egg turned into a chicken.
Jake: 然后爬到了桌上
Jake: And then climbed onto the table.
Jake: 又变成了鸡蛋
Jake: And turned back into an egg.
Tasha: 是的嗯
Tasha: Yes, indeed.
Tasha: 这是被我们惩罚的鸡蛋
Tasha: This is the egg we punished.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling about this.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:我有不太妙的预感
Alice: I really have a bad feeling.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: It's kind of impressive.
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Alice: I feel like this is going to go wrong.
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Okay, let me see.
Jake: 我来研究研究
Jake: Let me study this.
Jake: 它感觉要转出来了
Jake: It feels like it's about to turn out.
Alice: 大白菜还是太冒险了
Alice: The cabbage is still too risky.
Jake: 我也我也
Jake: Me too, me too.
Jake: 整不明白是吧
Jake: Can't figure it out, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 感觉他底下没有网
Lucia: Feels like there's no net underneath.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 那这哎
Jake: Then this, hey.
Jake: 哈哈哎呀那这个怎么办呀
Jake: Haha, hey, so what do we do about this?
Jake: 这也只能打开吧
Jake: We can only open it, right?
Lucia: 对他如果透出好像下不去哦有网
Lucia: Yeah, if it shows, it seems like it can't go down, there's a net.
Lucia: 这是一种试错觉的效果
Lucia: It's an illusionary effect.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Tasha: 我去开会了
Tasha: I'm going to a meeting.
Tasha: 5分钟时间
Tasha: Five minutes.
Tasha: 呃现在23   35吧
Tasha: Uh, now it's 23:35, right?
Alice: 不知道为什么
Alice: Don't know why.
Alice: 这个颜色变成这个样子了
Alice: This color has changed so much.
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Alice: I feel like it's going to be a disaster.
Alice: 怎么办好害怕
Alice: What should we do? I'm so scared.
Jake: 别怕别怕
Jake: Don't be scared, don't be scared.
Jake: 好吃
Jake: It's delicious.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it really good?
Jake: 好吃，对一定好吃
Jake: Yes, it’s definitely delicious.
Alice: 我我我已经开始害怕了
Alice: I-I-I'm starting to get really scared.
Alice: 有一种不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling about this.
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank.
Tasha: 充电宝有充电的吗
Tasha: Is there any power in the power bank?
Jake: 有的
Jake: Yes, there is.
Jake: 应该有吧
Jake: There should be.
Jake: 给你个46怎么样
Jake: How about a 46 for you?
Jake: 可是我没有充电线呀
Jake: But I don't have a charging cable.
Jake: 你是什么
Jake: What kind do you need?
Tasha: 我想要自带线的好苹果
Tasha: I want one with its own cable, preferably for Apple.
Alice: 喂没事没事
Alice: Hey, it's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 喂听不见听不见你说话
Tasha: Hey, I can't hear you, I can't hear what you're saying.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Alice: 白菜帮不要
Alice: No cabbage stalks.
Tasha: 听不见
Tasha: Can't hear you.
Alice: 啊可能是
Alice: Ah, maybe...
Alice: 呃没事再重拉一个
Alice: Uh, it's okay, let's redo it.
Jake: 对再拉
Jake: Yeah, redo it.
Jake: 刚刚我刚刚我头在下面一直一刀下去
Jake: Just now, I had my head down and went all in with one chop.
Jake: 哈哈哈感觉断头的感觉
Jake: Hahaha, felt like beheading.
Jake: 有一种哎呀Lucia你好像你好像
Jake: There's this feeling, ah Lucia, you seem like, you seem like...
Jake: 这个灯不亮了
Jake: This light isn't working.
Jake: 可能是满了
Jake: Maybe it's full.
Jake: 要不看一下
Jake: Want to check it?
Jake: 看一下吧
Jake: Check it out.
Jake: 满了或者他自己
Jake: It's either full or it just...
Tasha: 还是听不见哦
Tasha: Still can't hear you.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake: 没关系就在你那
Jake: It's fine, it's with you.
Tasha: 可不可能是我的问题
Tasha: Could it be my problem?
Tasha: 应该不是吧
Tasha: Probably not, right?
Jake: 没事吧就是在新开一个，然后照个准
Jake: It's okay, just open a new one and align it.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个灯还亮不亮
Jake: Let me check if your light is still on.
Jake: 关机了呢
Jake: It's turned off.
Jake: 关机了不知道怎么样关机了
Jake: It's turned off, I don't know why it turned off.
Lucia: 可他听了很长声音变
Lucia: But he listened to a long sound change.
Lucia: 我猜应该是我变了
Lucia: I guess it must have been me who changed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Let me check again.
Alice: 盐在哪里
Alice: Where's the salt?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 哦没电了哎
Jake: Oh, it's out of battery.
Jake: 为什么是没充上吗
Jake: Why is it, didn't it charge?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 没事哦感觉没没插进去
Jake: No worries, it doesn't seem to be plugged in properly.
Jake: 可能也不是
Jake: Or maybe not.
Jake: 啊只能插到这
Jake: It can only be plugged this much.
Jake: 那就不是没插进去
Jake: So it's not that it wasn't plugged in.
Lucia: 他这里有有一段不过可能中间他他啊
Lucia: There's a part here, but maybe in the middle, he, he, uh...
Jake: 没事没事没事继续
Jake: No worries, no worries, keep going.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 就要插着电了
Jake: It needs to be plugged in.
Jake: 刚好现在有兜了
Jake: Luckily, there's a pocket now.
Lucia: 对对对我刚好现在有兜了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, luckily I have a pocket now.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 这样的话其实是别人没电就你还有电
Jake: This way, actually, when others run out of battery, you still have power.
Jake: 呃行
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake: 因为大家可能很快
Jake: Because everyone might quickly...
Jake: 不是没有点是没有sorry
Jake: It's not that there's no point, it's just that there's no sorry.
Jake: 就你还有很多sorry
Jake: Only you have a lot of sorry.
Jake: 就是所有状况都可以解释
Jake: Every situation can be explained.
Jake: 最后写下来的时候都可以解决
Jake: When you finally write it down, it can all be resolved.
Jake: 现在好了
Jake: Now it's good.
Jake: 嗯现在是2024
Jake: Hmm, now it's 2024.
Jake: 4162028
Jake: 4162028.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧那就过一会吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait a bit.
Jake: 对对对充一会也放这
Jake: Yes, yes, charge it for a while and leave it here.
Jake: 放一会
Jake: Leave it for a while.
Tasha: 喂可以，你可以说话了刚我听见了
Tasha: Hey, it's fine, you can talk now, I heard you earlier.
Jake: 放到里面充吧
Jake: Put it inside to charge.
Lucia: 导数据
Lucia: Export the data.
Jake: 可以这样
Jake: You can do it like this.
Jake: 那你就是担当，接下来一晚上的担当
Jake: So you'll be in charge, in charge for the rest of the night.
Jake: 直接导数据好了
Jake: Just export the data directly.
Lucia: 哦哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice: 见你有种似曾相识的感觉喔哦耶
Alice: Seeing you gives me a sense of déjà vu, oh yeah.
Tasha: 哈哈 哈哈
Tasha: Haha, haha.
Tasha: 我我什么都没画在瞎画
Tasha: I, I didn't draw anything, just doodling.
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 没有没有我是说你在设计一个表情包
Lucia: No, no, I mean you're designing an emoji pack.
Tasha: 好我也希望
Tasha: I hope so too.
Tasha: 哇网好差啊
Tasha: Wow, the internet is so bad.
Jake: 跨跨服聊天
Jake: Cross-server chat.
Jake: 哈哈哈听到了一个
Jake: Haha, heard that one.
Alice: 有没有一种似曾相识的感觉喔哦耶
Alice: Doesn't it feel a bit familiar, oh yeah.
Alice: 累死我了
Alice: I'm exhausted.
Alice: 翻车翻车
Alice: It's a disaster.
Alice: 这个颜色不太对
Alice: This color isn't right.
Alice: 应该是奶白色的
Alice: It should be cream white.
Alice: 不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why.
Lucia: 哎绝了
Lucia: Oh, this is amazing.
Alice: 我很难受
Alice: I feel terrible.
Jake: 这个东西
Jake: This thing.
Jake: 保个温吧
Jake: Keep it warm.
Jake: 可以保温吗
Jake: Can it keep warm?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我扔薇波炉里面去
Jake: I'll throw it in the microwave.
Jake: 强势保温嗯
Jake: Strong heat retention, hmm.
Jake: 怎么有强势保温
Jake: How does it have strong heat retention?
Katrina:  咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Lucia: 我们的外卖到了
Lucia: Our takeout has arrived.
Jake: 哦强势保温
Jake: Oh, strong heat retention.
Lucia: 所以地上就放了一个火炉保温
Lucia: So there's a heater on the floor to keep it warm.
Jake: 对那这个没有
Jake: Yeah, but not this.
Jake: 有个电饭锅
Jake: There's a rice cooker.
Katrina:  这是什么啊哈哈哈
Katrina: What is this, haha.
Katrina:  哦我要买个东西
Katrina: Oh, I need to buy something.
Jake: 放不下
Jake: It won't fit.
Jake: 但是问题不大
Jake: But it's not a big problem.
Jake: 楼上我们还有一个
Jake: We have one more upstairs.
Tasha: 嗯嗯现在会议就开始了
Tasha: Mm-hmm, now the meeting starts.
Tasha: 然后我来点个名
Tasha: Then I'll take attendance.
Tasha: 就是呃
Tasha: So, um...
Tasha: 如果到了的同学我喊到名字的话
Tasha: If I call your name and you're here,
Tasha: 你就开个麦说一下可以到了就行
Tasha: just unmute and say you're here.
Tasha: 然后呃现在开始给你
Tasha: Alright, let's start.
Tasha: 第一个是肖费
Tasha: First is Xiao Fei.
Tasha: 第二个甲甲方廷
Tasha: Second, Jia Fangting.
Tasha: 甲方廷
Tasha: Jia Fangting.
Tasha: 第三个林国航
Tasha: Third, Lin Guohang.
Tasha: 林国航
Tasha: Lin Guohang.
Tasha: 第四个张锡丹
Tasha: Fourth, Zhang Xidan.
Katrina:  他今天中午说那个货币
Katrina: He mentioned that currency thing at noon today.
Tasha:董庆兴
Tasha: Dong Qingxing.
Katrina:  这个货币可不可以用这种贴纸来代替
Katrina: Can we use these stickers instead of currency?
Katrina:  因为这贴纸想要卖
Katrina: Because I want to sell these stickers.
Tasha:董庆兴
Tasha: Dong Qingxing.
Katrina:  不知道贴哪
Katrina: Not sure where to stick them.
Katrina:  贴了会留痕
Katrina: They might leave marks.
Katrina:  然后你那个货币的话
Katrina: And for that currency,
Katrina:  那你就得买游戏币做顺畅
Katrina: you'd have to buy game tokens for it to work smoothly.
Katrina:  买了也没啥用
Katrina: Buying them is pointless.
Tasha: 贺顺畅
Tasha: He Shunchang.
Lucia: 是可以节约一些日寸
Lucia: It can save some space.
Lucia: 而且贴纸留着
Lucia: And keep the stickers.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina: 贴纸时时刻刻提醒他们
Katrina: The stickers can remind them anytime.
Katrina:  参加过世界地球日的
Katrina: That they participated in Earth Day.
Tasha: 张博轩
Tasha: Zhang Boxuan.
Katrina:  那就把这个当货币吧
Katrina: Let's just use this as currency then.
Tasha: 张琳
Tasha: Zhang Lin.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 丁欢欢
Tasha: Ding Huanhuan.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:好的 王丹
Tasha: Okay, Wang Dan.
Katrina:  把所有的理下来脑子也就轻松了
Katrina: Once you sort everything out, your mind will be at ease.
Tasha: 宋梓月
Tasha: Song Ziyue.
Katrina:  这也便宜
Katrina: This is cheap too.
Tasha: 宋赵皓成
Tasha: Song Zhaohao
Tasha: 刘庆新
Tasha: Liu Qingxin
Tasha: 不好意思哈哈
Tasha: Sorry, haha.
Alice: 有没有人愿意先来尝一下毒
Alice: Is anyone willing to try this first?
Tasha: 彭浩南
Tasha: Peng Haonan
Tasha: 李鑫鹏
Tasha: Li Xinpeng
Alice: 但是这个颜色不知道为什么
Alice: But this color, I don't know why...
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it as a milky white color?
Tasha: 房柏晟
Tasha: Fang Baisheng
Alice: 不知道为什么他好黑
Alice: I don't know why it's so dark.
Alice: 我好难受
Alice: I feel so uncomfortable.
Tasha:陆宇
Tasha: Lu Yu
Alice: 因为皮蛋原因吧
Alice: Maybe because of the century egg.
Alice: 不是就是之前是白的不知道为什么
Alice: It was white before, don't know why...
Tasha:张路南
Tasha: Zhang Lunan
Alice: 这次啊乌漆嘛黑的
Alice: This time it's all black.
Alice: 可能没放牛奶或者怎样
Alice: Maybe there's no milk in it or something.
Tasha:姚浩然
Tasha: Yao Haoran
Alice: 你少盛一点吧
Alice: Just take a little bit.
Alice:: 害怕你受不了
Alice: I'm afraid you can't handle it.
Katrina:  哦还放牛奶
Katrina: Oh, there’s milk in it too?
Alice: 哎这个颜色好害怕呀
Alice: This color is so scary.
Tasha:姚浩然
Tasha: Yao Haoran
Katrina:  家人没关系
Katrina: It's okay, family.
Lucia: 嗯我这很害怕
Lucia: Hmm, I'm really scared.
Tasha: 姚昊然
Tasha: Yao Haoran
Katrina:  有勺吗
Katrina: Do we have a spoon?
Tasha: 赵倩琪
Tasha: Zhao Qianqi
Tasha: 木越南
Tasha: Mu Yuenan
Katrina:  这就像皮蛋瘦肉粥一样
Katrina: This is like century egg and lean pork congee.
Tasha: 邹百灵
Tasha: Zou Bailing
Katrina:  有勺吗哇这个颜色好死亡
Katrina: Do we have a spoon? Wow, this color is deadly.
Tasha: 陈新宇
Tasha: Chen Xinyu
Alice: 有筷子 用筷子
Alice: We have chopsticks. Use chopsticks.
Katrina:  那就用那个
Katrina: Then I'll use those.
Tasha:陈新宇
Tasha: Chen Xinyu
Katrina:  上次谁用的一次性书
Katrina: Who used a disposable book last time?
Tasha: 秦雪华
Tasha: Qin Xuehua
Katrina:  我去看一下
Katrina: I'll go check.
Tasha: 嗯连玉
Tasha: Hmm, Lian Yu
Alice: 张春楠
Alice: Zhang Chunnan
Tasha: 张继凯
Tasha: Zhang Jikai
Tasha: 啊好的
Tasha: Ah, okay
Tasha: 那就这样
Tasha: So that's it
Katrina:  那个筷子
Katrina: Those chopsticks
Katrina:  因为没有勺子
Katrina: Because there's no spoon
Katrina:  他做的
Katrina: He made it
Tasha:呃 你是 甲方廷 好的
Tasha: Uh, you are Jia Fangting, okay
Jake: 有勺子，有肯德基留下的勺子
Jake: There's a spoon, a leftover from KFC
Katrina:  哦在这在这
Katrina: Oh, here it is, here it is
Katrina:  嗯我决定就是今天
Katrina: Hmm, I decided it's today
Katrina:  呃修硕不是说那个货币嘛
Katrina: Uh, didn't Shure mention the currency?
Katrina:  嗯货币
Katrina: Hmm, currency
Katrina:  我就打算能不能用那个
Katrina: I was thinking if we could use that
Katrina:  我给你看那个贴纸他充当
Katrina: I'll show you the sticker he used
Katrina:  因为贴纸他确实没法什么贴
Katrina: Because the sticker can't really stick to anything
Katrina:  然后你买那货币的话
Katrina: And if you buy that currency
Katrina:  越买游戏币也没啥用对吧
Katrina: The more you buy game coins, the more useless they are, right?
Katrina:  那样的话
Katrina: So in that case
Katrina:  时时刻刻提醒他们
Katrina: It constantly reminds them
Katrina:  参加过世界地球日的活动
Katrina: To participate in Earth Day activities
Alice: 挺好再摔几次他不就死掉了
Alice: Great, if it falls a few more times, it'll break
Katrina: : 贴纸还便宜
Katrina: Stickers are cheap too
Alice: 换个位置吧
Alice: Let's switch places
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 都是人才
Jake: Everyone is talented
Katrina:  拿这个勺试试
Katrina: Try this spoon
Katrina:  尝一下
Katrina: Have a taste
Tasha:结束了
Tasha: It's over
Tasha: 开会啊不是结束了
Tasha: The meeting is over, right?
Katrina:  嗯味道挺好的
Katrina: Hmm, it tastes pretty good
Alice: 你要喝吗？这个颜色有点死亡你饿了吗
Alice: Do you want to drink it? The color looks a bit deadly. Are you hungry?
Tasha: 呃没有好喝吗
Tasha: Uh, no. Is it good?
Alice: 你要来点吗
Alice: Want some?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Alice:这颜色
Alice: This color
Tasha: 我先尝一口
Tasha: I'll taste it first
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it being milky white?
Tasha: 啊怎么会变成这个颜色
Tasha: Ah, how did it become this color?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 我想先尝尝咸淡
Tasha: I want to taste it first to check the saltiness.
Alice: 你拿直接勺吧
Alice: Just use a spoon directly.
Alice: 有没有别的
Alice: Is there anything else?
Tasha: 嗯我觉得可以
Tasha: Hmm, I think it's okay.
Alice: 咸吗
Alice: Is it salty?
Tasha: 我觉得可以再加一点点盐
Tasha: I think we can add a little bit more salt.
Alice: 再加点盐
Alice: Add more salt.
Katrina:  有点咸
Katrina: It's a bit salty.
Tasha: 是吗嗯那可能我喝的有点少吧
Tasha: Really? Hmm, maybe I didn't drink enough.
Alice: 有点咸还有点甜
Alice: It's a bit salty and a bit sweet.
Katrina:  咸，不是我吃正好不用加盐了我的意思是
Katrina: Salty, no, I mean it's just right for me, no need to add more salt.
Alice: 你要加盐吗
Alice: Do you want to add salt?
Tasha: 呃我不加了
Tasha: Uh, I won't add more.
Tasha: 呃给我也来一碗
Tasha: Uh, give me a bowl too.
Alice: 你自己来点吧
Alice: Serve yourself some.
Tasha: 呃不了不了你帮我加一碗就行了
Tasha: Uh, no, no, you can serve me a bowl.
Tasha: 为什么大家不吃饭
Tasha: Why isn't everyone eating?
Alice: 还没到吧
Alice: Maybe it's not time yet.
Tasha: 哎刚刚饭不是到了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't the food arrive just now?
Katrina:  把它因为我我也不知道
Katrina: Because I, I don't know either.
Katrina:  哈哈开玩笑的
Katrina: Haha, just kidding.
Alice: 给 你饿了吗
Alice: Here, are you hungry?
Alice: 多吗
Alice: Is it too much?
Tasha: 呃 呵呵
Tasha: Uh, hehe.
Alice: 你倒入一点
Alice: Pour a bit in.
Tasha: 大家一人有一碗吗
Tasha: Does everyone have a bowl?
Alice: 足足的
Alice: Plenty.
Tasha: 好 我问一下   饭呢
Tasha: Okay, let me ask. Where's the food?
Tasha: 什么时候吃饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Jake: 已经饭已经到了
Jake: The food has already arrived.
Jake: 饭已经到了
Jake: The food has arrived.
Tasha: 在哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Tasha: 吃呀
Tasha: Let's eat!
Tasha: 走吗
Tasha: Are we going?
Jake: 走
Jake: Yeah, let's go.
Tasha: 为啥不吃
Tasha: Why aren't we eating?
Jake: 因为不是在等这个
Jake: Because we're waiting for the freshly made food.
Jake: 那个新做的饭吗
Jake: The new food, right?
Jake: 那个
Jake: The...
Tasha: 哦 做好了都
Tasha: Oh, it's all done.
Jake: 好 那我不知道呀
Jake: Okay, I didn't know that.
Jake: 现在知道了对
Jake: Now I know, right?
Lucia: 好激动啊
Lucia: So excited!
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 你好像在那边在跳舞然后在斗舞
Jake: You seem to be dancing over there, having a dance battle.
Jake: 在斗舞就是
Jake: Dance battling, right?
Tasha: 什么来着哼
Tasha: What was it, huh?
Tasha: 哎我还学过一段时间呢
Tasha: Oh, I even learned it for a while.
Tasha: 学的啥呀
Tasha: What did I learn?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Jake: 斗舞是吧
Jake: Dance battle, right?
Tasha: 好了大家都下来吃饭了
Tasha: Okay, everyone come down to eat.
Tasha: 不过为什么不在上面吃呢
Tasha: But why don't we eat upstairs?
Lucia: 因为土豆里下面好像比上面多一点
Lucia: Because there seems to be more food downstairs than upstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我想把这个拿上去吃
Lucia: I want to take this upstairs to eat.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你要不要把那个锅拿上去
Tasha: Do you want to take that pot upstairs?
Tasha: 嗯把这碗汤汤端上去
Tasha: Hmm, take this bowl of soup upstairs.
Alice: 端上去
Alice: Take it upstairs.
Tasha: 对因为不是在上面吃饭吗
Tasha: Yeah, because we're eating upstairs, right?
Jake: 好我先端上去
Jake: Okay, I'll take it up first.
Lucia: 这个袋子好像也有汤的样子
Lucia: This bag seems to have soup too.
Tasha: 水煮肉片吧
Tasha: It's boiled meat slices.
Alice: 哎把它想象成
Alice: Hey, imagine it as
Alice: 奶白色的话会不会好点
Alice: milky white, would it be better?
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: I can't stand it.
Alice: 这乌漆嘛黑的好难过
Alice: This dark color is so depressing.
Alice: 好了吗
Alice: Is it ready?
Tasha: 啊不是呃
Tasha: Oh, no, uh
Tasha: 换个温度
Tasha: Change the temperature.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 端上去吗
Tasha: Take it upstairs?
Tasha: 嗯在楼上吃晚饭
Tasha: Hmm, having dinner upstairs.
Tasha: OK把我的端上去
Tasha: OK, take mine up.
Lucia:  端上去吧
Lucia: Take it up.
Lucia: 上面桌子稍微空点
Lucia: There's a bit more space on the table upstairs.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 我又受到熏陶了
Tasha: I feel enlightened again.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 一起听吧你
Jake: Listen together.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How is it?
Tasha: 不应该说这些啊
Tasha: I shouldn't say that.
Jake: 哈哈这是Siri吗猜PPT
Jake: Haha, is this Siri guessing the PPT?
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 这是课吗
Jake: Is this a class?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 好了别听了
Tasha: Alright, stop listening.
Tasha: 污染耳朵了
Tasha: It's polluting our ears.
Tasha: 啊不应该说这些话啊
Tasha: Ah, I shouldn't say these things.
Tasha: 不好意思
Tasha: Sorry.
Tasha: 嘿是不是要拿个饮料上去哦
Tasha: Hey, do we need to bring a drink upstairs?
Tasha: 上面再饮用饮料是吧
Tasha: Can we drink upstairs?
Lucia: 把果粒橙拿上去了
Lucia: Bring the pulpy orange juice.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 拆了要不然
Lucia: Open it, maybe?
Tasha: 那那
Tasha: Here, here.
Alice:上面是不是没有留碗呀
Alice: Is there no bowl upstairs?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia: 上面也有碗，就在那个橱柜里
Lucia: There are bowls upstairs, in the cabinet.
Tasha: 这个这个杯子都洗过了吗
Tasha: Have these cups been washed?
Lucia: 呃可能还没有哎
Lucia: Uh, maybe not yet.
Tasha: 楼上有杯子吗
Tasha: Are there cups upstairs?
Lucia: 楼上应该也有
Lucia: There should be.
Tasha: 那那去楼上吧
Tasha: Then let's go upstairs.
Tasha: 还有东西要端吗
Tasha: Do we need to carry anything else?
Tasha: 那个汤要不要端着
Tasha: Do we need to bring the soup?
Alice:端吧
Alice: Sure, bring it.
Tasha: 还有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Anything else to take?
Tasha: 应该没有了吧
Tasha: Should be nothing else, right?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Tasha: 我帮你拿一个吧
Tasha: I'll help you carry one.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go.
Lucia: 啊 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you.
Tasha: 好拿吗
Tasha: Is it easy to carry?
Alice:有点多
Alice: It's a bit much.
Tasha: 呵呵呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehehe
Alice:这颜色
Alice: This color...
Tasha: 有点黑暗的感觉
Tasha: It feels a bit dark.
Alice:不知道它为什么变成这个颜色
Alice: I don't know why it turned this color.
Tasha: 有点黑暗的感觉
Tasha: It feels a bit dark.
Jake: 什么怎么黑暗了
Jake: What do you mean dark?
Alice:这个颜色不太对劲
Alice: This color is off.
Jake: 这叫胡辣汤
Jake: This is called Hulatang.
Tasha: 说的好
Tasha: Well said.
Jake: 是里边什么皮蛋放多了
Jake: Maybe there's too much century egg in it.
Alice: 不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Alice: 可能是水刚热的时候没有立即放进去
Alice: Maybe it wasn't put in immediately when the water was hot.
Alice: 热水放一碗
Alice: Pour a bowl of hot water.
Alice: 这干净的
Alice: Is this clean?
Alice: 碗吗
Alice: The bowl?
Tasha: 我觉得要洗吧
Tasha: I think it needs to be washed.
Tasha: 要不要给大家洗几个杯子
Tasha: Should we wash a few cups for everyone?
Tasha: 放到那里吧
Tasha: Put it there.
Tasha: 放到桌上吧
Tasha: Put it on the table.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice: 占地吗？
Alice: Does it take up space?
Tasha: 不占地
Tasha: No, it doesn't.
Tasha: 这是汤
Tasha: This is soup.
Katrina:  这是汤吗
Katrina: Is this soup?
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 我们有点汤吗
Tasha: Do we have some soup?
Lucia: 我们没点汤
Lucia: We didn't order soup.
Lucia: 这是番茄牛腩吗
Lucia: Is this tomato beef?
Tasha: 我靠这是番茄牛腩
Tasha: Oh my, this is tomato beef.
Lucia: 它看起来好像番茄汤啊
Lucia: It looks like tomato soup.
Tasha: 有备注不要香菜吗
Tasha: Did we note no cilantro?
Alice: 哎最后谁下单的啊
Alice: Hey, who placed the order in the end?
Jake:呃 挑出来，我可以都挑出来 行不
Jake: Uh, pick it out, I can pick it all out, okay?
Alice: 这番茄牛腩太离谱了吧
Alice: This tomato beef is ridiculous.
Alice: 你能不能联系一下商家
Alice: Can you contact the vendor?
Alice: 你问问他
Alice: Ask them.
Alice: 这个真的是番茄牛腩
Alice: Is this really tomato beef?